I've been starting to play chess
basically like you know most of the kids
that I see here you know the ages five
six seven I mean this is where people
start playing chess and I think that
means many others are not any difference
so let's start to make our really really
first steps in the game before we start
discussing moves and what opening should
I play and all those big questions that
are much much further down the road I
would like to ask you a question the
game of chess
what does it resembles to any one of you
I mean like if you have an answer you
can raise your hand preferably so you
won't speak one on the other but when
you think about chess what does it seem
like yes
okay you try to take the king that's
that's correct and we'll take it a bit
more yes explaining so in another words
it's basically a battle right it's it's
basically like it's a war right you you
want to take over the king the kingdom
you know whichever word that you want to
use but it is a war and it is a very
fair war right we know very clearly the
army of the white army of black they're
exactly identical right you know
fighting wars in the world one army is
bigger one now me smaller you know it's
not really the same not only that you
start with exactly same territory
sixteen pieces on sixteen squares the
board is very clear so it's in this way
it's a wall that very very clear the
battlefield is very clear it's 64
squares now if we all agree the chess is
a battle played over very clear rules
very clear armies and space now we are
coming to the bottom all today really
understanding of what chess is all about
and understanding what is battle is
about is the key whether you're gonna
make your next move playing the next
tournament or you're going to move up
you're going to play in city
championship state championship World
Championships whatever everyone obeys
basically and follows the same
principles and ideas of the game so a
batter what's important in a battle who
wins battle usually that's it that is
like 90% of the answer the one that has
more units right I mean you are
answering in chess pieces but if I will
take you out no 2,000 years ago 2500
years ago to some Roman fights in
battles you know you would say okay this
army is X amount of soldiers these
armies
that amount of soldiers usually we would
prefer the bigger army right it's not
saying always the bigger army wins but
it's it's a big advantage so material
this will be our part of chess right you
have more material you're gonna win the
game
forget about army for a second you see a
soccer game usually we start with ten
players and a goalkeeper
but let's say that you see from some
reason one team at eight players and the
other one is ten wouldn't you think that
the one with the ten players is more
likely to win the game so right but this
is already your right is this tiny bit
upper the upper stage but let's say that
all the players are the same no the one
with the Templars will have much better
possibilities to win the battle right so
this is 90 plot well almost actually
hundred percent to beginners level to
kid level this is really 100 percent if
you will all go over games that you
played either if you played in
tournaments or if you played with your
parents or like I started playing chess
I started playing with my grandfather my
father also played chess my older
brother was actually a decent chess
player but you know usually many people
stopped playing chess in the family if
you think about all games that you
played some of them you have written
down I'm willing to clearly state that
all your game so far has been decided
because of two reasons either one
somehow overlooked the checkmate
which is a very specific thing in chess
or really really more material winning
or losing a lot of material so material
is as close as possible to hundred
percent of decisive game at this level
now let's move little bit half little
bit up other than material what else is
important yes
space this is someone that study chess
right why do you think space is
important that's that's exactly the
second one why do you think space is
important
okay-y wife you have more room it's
better then if your opponent has less
well what did it really give you yes
okay
right but but this is just part of the
chess rules right the Kings cannot touch
one another but I think that what was
your name what Wellston what he said
about spacing means basically that part
of big advantages that we will have is
the body 64 squares let's say that one
player managed to control 40 squares the
opponent is left with 24 squares
why would that be an advantage it's
actually this I think the second most
important part after material you know
let's forget for a second about this
being a chessboard let's think about
this being a soccer field well playing
soccer and this is the goal area we need
to score in this area do you think that
an army that is all only on those three
ranks this is what the armies will it
have better chances to score here as
opposed to the white army that's
controlling all these three or five
banks and can get these units safely
here and then all you need to scroll is
here which one would you prefer why
because when you have more space this is
soccer forget about chess you have more
ability to maneuver the ball to attack
actually where the goal is you just have
more more space equals more
possibilities the opponent has less
possibilities yes
exactly because that is the part that
when you have two things one is more
space for the attacking pieces and the
other one for the defender you cannot
really easily move right because it is
cramped exactly but we will get to that
part you know you know what is so
amazing about chess that the word and
this is important for everyone that
making their first steps I will give you
all an example let's say that you ever
move and you play you see a move your
opponent has four possibility five
possibilities if he plays fall of them
you win on the spot you win on the spot
but if you place one of them you get
into a losing position so let's do it
slowly for the opponent has five moves
four of them you win on the spot but if
you play one movies best move you lose
immediately should you play such a move
or not should you say mmm I've 80%
chance to win the game immediately I
should go for it why not
because because this this is remember
how we started we said the chest is a
very fair battle I am NOT holding cards
and you don't know if I have two and
five or if I have two aces right let's
assuming we are playing poker
you don't know in poker what I have
right this is why this game is a bit
different than chess in chest everything
is here
everything there is no such a thing
maybe my opponent didn't see ok it means
he made a big mistake but there is no
real reason for him not to see what's
here if you are attacking a screen well
these eyes you will see that so the
assumption the idea of saying well I
remove 80% chance I'm winning and 20%
chance I'm losing equal 100% chance you
are losing 100% because we always have
to play based on our opponents is the
best tricking so this is for that idea
that was very important for me just when
we are starting there is no I flip a
coin maybe I'm playing the odds
mm-hm chess is an absolute game
everything is here everything there is
nothing hidden behind the boat so
speaking about space let's say that one
player controls more squares let's go
let's go tiny bit deeper into this idea
would you think that there are some
squares on the board at all
somewhat worthy more than others some
squares that you like to control more
than other middle squares why the middle
squares
let's go back to our stock your example
right well soccer is easy I probably
played soccer before I play chess oh yes
so that there are several reasons mainly
mainly this is like I can take a bishop
I can put any unity let's just put it
the other way
let consider this is a soccer player he
has no possibilities to pass the ball to
their King side right side of the King
now let's call it right to the center to
the left it's really in a best position
right well if he was here well I think
it's very difficult for those parts to
communicate well this starter player
right it's not a bishop can maybe pass
the ball here maybe can pass the ball
here you cannot pass the ball to the
other side if you want to go tiny bit
and see a real example to it what do you
think what do you think apartments will
cost most it's exactly the center of the
city or far away from the center of the
city usually the center you exactly
usually at the center it is because it
gives you the possibility to you know I
grew up in Israel I'm from Israel and I
grew up in the center of very close to
Tel Aviv and I can tell you that where I
live I need I in two minutes walking
there was any everything that I possibly
needed you know I was a young kid but
everything from supermarkets to movie
theaters to post office to back
everything was there well that's why in
general it's a bit more expensive so
this territory is a bit more expensive
this is why let's get our soccer player
back and make him back a bishop this is
why how do we start playing chess do you
think that this is a decent move to
start
so if we are speaking about space we
will have in chess I would say that
there are about four moves to start the
game divide it into two big groups but
there are basically two two main moves
or forming moves either way we wanna
count it
who can suggest me move so if you want
if someone who only weighs is handing
can play on the body move yes Queen pawn
so you want to play d4 right okay d4
queen pawn going to d4
this is usually the second move the
first move that almost everyone but but
it's actually a bit more popular I think
at high level these days which one keep
on okay so this is what almost everyone
is playing king of if all right we have
the board marked with letters and
numbers so we will just put you know if
you play ping pong
that's how they used to speak hundreds
fifty years ago in old old book the
notation was exactly like that they
would put King pawn for and sometimes
they would refer this as this is King
Bishop right and this is the Queen
Bishop that's crazy
you know the algebraic notation is so
much easier that's why they change it
but you're right King pawn so we would
play evil we will play d4 right another
move that was mentioned that is in the
same family as default before is a
family that has I would say two other
moves one of them is Knight to f3 oh if
I would have to say it in the old way
they used to say probably I would say
Knight King Bishop three complicated
there that because this is the bishop
that belongs to the King King Bishop
three Knight f3 MOT simple right Knight
f3 okay
why this move Knight f3 and default
almost the same because they control
about the same squares right the pawn
control
all five in c-five the night control if
I default these three five girl they're
about the same and then we would have
one other may move that is part of the
default family if I had to say it is the
move c4 which basically controls again
this crucial square d5 and controls also
another squirrel a bit less important
but this is one major way to develop in
almost all the strong players in the
world if you go the list of the top
hundred players in the world I mean okay
obviously they all play one of those
four openings and somehow you know it's
being divided between an e4 d for today
actually some c4 is becoming quite
popular but the idea is that we want to
fight over you know I like to call it
the small you know 64 squirrels but
there is this important square in the
middle those 16 squirrels this is what
we are also fighting so let's just
continue tiny bit this idea let's say
that I played easy for what are the
common replies that we know black can
play here monitor c5 you know the name
of this one Sicilian defense okay why
why think this move which is by far by
far by far the most popular move why do
you think this movie so popular
but you you mentioned one square
you mentioned months we all right I
heard it you mentioned d4 here's my
question
can white play easily before now that's
why we put the pawn here this pawn right
controls the other key central square
for white so Sicilian move basically
aiming immediately to fight for D square
by the way the other next move which is
more classical was played almost if I
was played almost every 150 years ago
King pawn move king prawn move most
classical approach we have to fight for
the center right 5-10 minutes ago we
established how important it is because
the center will give us more
possibilities so this is what we are
fighting just in another one minute two
other main openings of the French
defense played by several world
champions the idea is that black is
voluntarily giving white tiny bit more
space right look at that white has two
points on the fourth-ranked black as one
and one is a backward pawn but black
idea is that you will be able to for
example exploit some of his opponent
developing or important all opponent
moving forward mainly for example if you
look at this line then black is playing
a move like c5 targeting this point this
is the logic sometimes we do give space
if we believe that the opponent is
creating some weaknesses and the other
last opening I will just mention quickly
has a very much the same idea
which is the move sistex the caro-kann
opening again the idea is to play d5 if
Y to play before this is almost
automatic reply and black is fighting
from the fighting for the center tiny
bit from behind but fighting from the
center tiny bit from behind now some
other openings if we can just complete
the names you know let's just die just
dream also let's take another minute to
do that there is d6 of g6 they are
basically the same opening d6 white
wants to control this black to control
the square this is the Pierce opening
there is d5 Scandinavian or counter
Center right immediately attacking the
centre n9 f6 Alekhine this name other
kind does someone who someone can tell
me who is this name who is this person's
something Grandmaster is more than a
Grandmaster it was a grandmother but a
bit more than a grandmaster he was the
fourth world champion the fourth world
champion right the first world champion
was Williams tiny Emanuel a scale
capablanca was the third one and
Alexander are the kind actually the
first Russian world champion now Russia
is the most important country in the
world for chess but it was the first
world champion from Russia beat
Capablanca in 1927 by the way if you
listen carefully almost all the names in
of openings in chess almost all the
names are either locations cities
countries what what do with Sicilian
French Spanish when some lines in the
Spanish can be the Italian all named
after players world champion and some
many other grandmaster that play this a
lot okay great so we understand two
things we understand the chess is a game
of material and the chess is a game of
space anything else
can wait and I can tell you you know I'm
looking at this big room full of many
many many kids which is really great for
their many coming years you will have to
think about material sometimes I ask
people what is chess they tell me
strategy game strategy is a beautiful
world it's too complicated for me right
now
first let me understand how I play let
me understand how I keep my pieces
because if I will keep my pieces and I
will manage to win some of my opponent
pieces well I will have a bigger army if
I would have a bigger army I would have
much better possibilities to actually
checkmate my opponent if we want to
touch just quickly the rest of the
principles just opening principles what
would you say after material and space
is important yes what is that what does
tactic mean
but I will just ask you a question or
all mentioned forget about chess forget
about this boat we are two thousand
keels back right
we are fighting some battle for the
Roman Empire two thousand two thousand
five hundred we have hundreds of it what
is important we know we know that we
want to have more units we know that we
want to have more space what else is
important now you are coming to some two
tiny bit this world of strategy for
example let me let me help you bit if I
will tell you that how to deploy your
unit is important
would you agree with that where you put
them on the board did this is this is
really really when the armies are about
the same right the armies are about to
similar at the same level if one if one
has hundred thousand soldiers and the
other one is ten thousand strategy is
less important almost always right I
mean still it's important but it's
really not important but let's sit down
these are about the same okay in chess
it's perfect they are about the same but
let's say one army is hundred thousand
other one is ninety thousand a huge
difference then really what you do with
your pieces unit is important so we know
already that we want to move the pawns
to the center because our first
assumption is that this small square is
really important
let us give example from just let's say
that we will play this move fo and the
opponent will play this move e5 what
will be a logical next move for white
yes
night of3 perfect why you wanna play
Knight f3
perfect you know if we have things in
the basement you know it's not gonna
help or if we are taking it to sport
well if you have things you know sitting
on your bench not helping you need to
have them in the actual game then it's
worth something
so continuing what we spoke before we
want to control space and we want to
have our pieces to come and help us to
do that okay let's say the black wheel
see your threat and say okay you want to
attack my central pawn and you're
developing I can do the same let me take
my knife move it out develop and defend
now I will stop you for a second and say
this if we believe that chess games are
mainly especially at lower level being
worn by material what are the first
things that you should be thinking in
any given position chess gains are being
won by material let's say that we all
agree on that then what should we always
be thinking and every move any move but
developing pieces is right but let's say
that were in the middle game our pieces
are developed what should we be thinking
about our possibilities and our opponent
possibilities after your past day you're
in the attacking stage yes yes how do
you get more material you tell you up on
it please believe me your bishop so how
you do that
let's say that I was that black was
playing this move black was sleeping and
playing this meaningless man what would
you play you know what I would play that
move too so
in order to win material in order to win
material
well we actually need to capture like
you know it's like this this joke and
that's really important because you will
see it a lot in your game like this
woman was praying to God I want to win
the lottery I wanna win the lottery one
after like 10 years if they said just
buy ticket you know how to spy ticket
the same way you know we are speaking
about material and people say yeah it's
so important but then they forget to
play the basic thing the captures right
this was excellent because you know I've
seen many many games and it actually
appears in many books people have
similar position to this what many young
players will say oh I want to attack the
pawn on e5 I will play d4 now I'm
attacking it no they can capture and you
will capture back that is right it is
wrong as opposed to capture immediately
perfect perfect but the logic is saying
I want to attack I want to attack up
just capture it you don't need to attack
it anymore by the way you know the
simple part about chess simple is that
there are only two players only two
players black white white black so by
definition it's not complicated right
you don't have three armies four armies
carrots
really not complicated yeah you know
what's good what's good for white my
definition has to be bad for black and
what is good for black by definition has
to be bad for white it's very simple
very very simple it's not like you know
maybe he is okay but he is this and
there's no there is no third party or
fourth party so if we understand this we
will also think about something else
let's say that white played white ladies
move
it's not horrible move and black play
this move now which moves should white
play here all which move would you
consider playing for white yes Knight f3
is a possible move it yes okay one thing
that you said is perfect they move I
like tiny less so basically you're
thinking use first of all see the reason
why or opponent ladies last move your
pawn a played Knight f6 because he wants
to capture the pawn and you in an
excellent way want to defend the pawn
there is and why I will tell you very
quickly why I do not like this move so
much is because it is not very natural
you want to castle at some point right
we will touch this point a bit after how
many how many units of pawns or whatever
you wanna call them you have to block
this diagonal before you castle so if
though your opponent will take this move
Bishop c5 it might be a bit more
difficult for you to castle so I will
say this I totally agree with what you
said I just want to play a little bit
better move to achieve the same goal a
little bit
so which better move can I play to
achieve exactly the same goal
perfect pawn from d2 to d3 someone
suggested Bishop g2 before I like this
move also actually it's very logical
right you will defend I
exactly exactly put if we play g3 we
will put the bishop on g2 and by the way
in chess the idea is fan chatter exactly
when we put the bishop on dough squares
that's the chess term for that so I want
to ask you all the question and think
carefully before you answer is it more
important for us to think about our
threat and our ideas or is it more
important to think about our opponent to
act in our opponent ideas yes alicorn 20
90s I'm sorry our turtle now it is yeah
okay you know what I will be more fair
okay because because maybe you are
answering it perfectly I will put three
possibilities our threats and our ideas
our own effort in our opponents ideas
and they are equally important
we cannot play chess we cannot
impossible and amazingly enough I've
seen some decent players okay youngsters
that actually that not thinking so much
about the opponent ideas and there are
really decent players it just means I
mean they don't completely overlook them
but not too much but what happened there
are only two players well what else are
you thinking if you tell me Luke there
are 10 armies and I I didn't see what
one army maneuvering and I was focusing
on the other eight armies of seven
armies oh okay I can understand it what
else there is to focus you wanna beat
your opponent you're white your opponent
wants to beat you if you will what
happen if you have a position that you
are threatening checkmate in three moves
you have a combination that is a false
checkmate in three moves the opponent
has the same position only that is
threatening checkmate in two moves
should you continue with your plan or
should you stop his length stop his plan
because who it's going to be checkmated
faster you're your opponent here's your
new right because he is checkmating you
in two moves now let's do it the other
way you have checkmate in three moves
and your point has checkmate informal
should you continue with your plan oh so
it is impossible be impossible look at
the same position impossible to say I
want to only think about my plan or I
want to think about my opponent plain if
you think about your own plan you say
I'm gonna check with my opponent into a
move let me go ahead okay if you check
my clean you in fall well you are right
if you check making you into you lost
the game so the right way the only way
only only way both and you know this is
the most difficult part for kids you
know I'm fortunate enough that I get to
teach some of the best kids in this
country some kids that won Nationals
that are ranked the top five for the age
group in the entire country well it's a
great pleasure and I mean you know it's
it's great to do that and you see from
with many of them at low
levels when they started it's just the
nature that it's very difficult for kids
like you to think about what the
opponent want to do it's very difficult
because we always we always like maybe
as human right we all think I want these
and I want to do that and well I'm here
and the world is surrounding around me
and not the other way around but it's
not going to work in chess because you
just gonna overlook your opponent ideas
for example you know there's so many
example that a player is attacking a
knight but you know what is opponent
last move was to attack your Queen and
you know we know what to keep do and I
want to bother you so you won't do that
I can take the knight without thinking
half a second
they take denied they are so happy
they're a knight up another two seconds
the queen is gone so from this tiny part
that we started speaking about
developing we get to the idea of
thinking about our opponent moves as
well as no other way so now let's
continue our game
what will we play now what is a
reasonable move for white in this
position
Bishop to see that the Italian I
mentioned did the Italian game okay why
do you wanna play Bishop c4 to control
center and you want yours you are
referring to this pond right okay Bishop
c4 is one of the main moves Bishop to b5
is probably considered a main move the
way you play as one of the oldest
opening in chess
Bishop c4 I would say this the logic is
that we are developing developing more
concrete ideas yeah we want to sometimes
we want at least to look I this pond
maybe for potential pressure excellent
let's say that black says you know what
good for you look for me I'll play here
this is very normal
what is white what will white play now
castle now big question why castle what
is the logic of castle yes excellent
this is the may not the only but the
very very main reason but why now second
question why castling keeping the king
safe
perfect but I will keep bothering you
why in the centre you don't have pieces
or pawns in front of him to defend it
why in the center when the king is here
right basically you will perfect
I want you one more answer perfect you
told me that if I move the King it's to
keep him safe that's correct then I
asked you why is it safe you said
because when you castle you will have
pieces or pawned around it to keep him
safe why not in the center why why the
King has to leave the center why this
would be one or it's easier to attack in
the center but I would say the second
one that is based on what we said when
we just doubted logic we have to use it
we put push our central pawns to do what
they have a job those pawns have a job
what is their job to fight for the
center so if we move our pawns to fight
for the center we weaken our King that's
why we will castle that was perfect very
very nice everything is said because now
by the way continue would randomly
randomly pushing this pawn make any
sense
it will defy any everything that you
just said right because we move the King
there to be safe not to just weaken him
what is the second tiny reason why we
castle there is a second time yeah
there's a second reason yes
connect the rooks exactly exactly
the book was here at some point we will
want to move the knight the bishop the
Queen and our works will connect right
it this is the right thing but obviously
the safety of the King is the most
important one let's say that black says
okay you know what good for me I want a
castle also the deities checkmate even
the fastest one that can be in two moves
but we are now playing decent chess
games you know this position has been
played by world champions has been
played by best players in the world by
many grandmasters let let us play two
three more moves what should what should
white play here a logical move for white
yes
I mean the one next to you
do it - which girl - g5 okay the logic
we will discuss this movie in a second
is there another idea yes
you never Castle anymore but but here's
my question
I agree so this is week and this is week
white potentially ha but is the isn't
the center a bit weaker you know you I
will tell something you are young right
you cannot avoid doing things would you
believe me if I tell you that if you
cross the street there is some risk into
it there is right but what we do what we
do when we cross the street to minimize
the risk of cows right what we do you
know III III had and have and have a
very very Jewish mother so I heard it
about million times I probably probably
also when I was 30 so you look left you
look right you listen you cross it when
the light is green to walk and so on
right that's what you do and why you do
that because it's the safest way to
cross does it mean that God forbid that
something never can happen sadly enough
it happens but it means that if you do
those no this is important because it's
about Jason you know with my student and
many others I like also it's very
important for me to take the logic from
chess and maybe tiny bit maybe more than
tiny bit implemented to life right
chef since I'm five the same is valid
that was here the same as yasiel that
was you know we all play chess since we
were young kids and each one of us go to
whatever you know high level in chess
you know yourself managed to beat
several world champion which is amazing
I can say my peak was I was world
champion under 16 long ago when I was 16
and in value no played for the only
national Olympic team and won many other
events and probably many other that I
hope you won't get mad at me for not
remembering each one of them but I will
say this we play just as well your age
and just it's part of our life so we
want to take the logic of chess and
implement it in other things you cannot
do something say you know I still have
risk even crossing the road in the
safest way is not totally secure
but maybe then we can bring defenders
but I will say this I understand what
you're saying and I think that and
you've said many many small things today
I have to disagree with you about that I
have to disagree with you I want to tell
you that you're right but then I will
have to be wrong about what I think and
you know when I proven mistaken chest
but when I proved it I made a mistake
I'm the first one to admit it and move
on but this is too much let's continue
95 was the move that was suggested any
other move for white yes a three but
yeah you see the crowd was saying no
white knight to f3 I know you can take
and we will capture a bit but I have a
question simple one if it's left to play
is black remember your opponent player
move you ask yourself you ask yourself
why did he play this move what is this
threat this is it automatically he
played the move why did he play this
move so it is black happening right now
something yes
Bishop to d3 okay Oh Knight g5 any other
moves yes
Knight to c3 that's better that's better
and something else before yeah but it's
play Evans gambit played when the
Knights out there it is you avoid but
it's played a move earlier all just
another move d3 I wanna I want to say
why I have tiny problems with Bishop d3
and 9 3 5 there are not mistakes but
they will they are working against a
very important opening principle that we
wanna touch
let's start with a big question we were
speaking before right about deploying
our pistes our unit in in a battle
so in chess will we prefer to have one
piece move four times or to have four
pieces move once and be part of the game
so we want to have more units
participating in the game I no matter
how great any player been in history you
know Michael Jordan couldn't have worn
worn all the championships that he want
without having some other great players
next to him impossible that doesn't
happen and there have been many many
great players that never had anyone next
to them and couldn't win so chess is
like any sport event we have to work as
a team if you say oh I will develop my
Queen fast and checkmate the opponent
that is one of the worst strategy
because the opponent will see it defend
and then will push you back so when I
play Bishop d3 felting I move this
Bishop already twice well for example 93
achieve exactly the same goal defending
this pawn it achieves exactly the same
goal and guess what I'm gay
that's the other thing I wanted to touch
it's getting another piece in the battle
so now I have two knights and a bishop
as opposed to move the bishop again and
not blocking why this move is a very
logical also because we did that we move
our pawn and we open this diagonal for
this Bishop Bishop d3 going to make it
tiny bit more difficult for us to
develop now there was a suggestion to
play Knight g5 which is a decent idea
actually now White has a threat to win
the game on the spot
what is this threat to win the game on
the spot why does the trap you will win
the game on the spot you are black each
and every one of you seeking form the
black side your opponent it not
checkmate immediately but it's a very
strong threat your opponent played 95
and you are thinking and asking yourself
why did my opponent play this move what
easy stretch
yes what is white strength good move
Knight good move not the best but good
movie the start but basically what you
are seeing exactly so basically right
now we we agree on one thing
Bishop take or Knight take to be more
precise Knight take is better exactly
for the reason that you mentioned
exactly Knight capture will attack the
Queen and will attack the hawk it will
be a fork in winning material exactly
bishop take will win a pawn and will
force the King to move but either way if
we are black right now look what we did
first of all we identify the opponent's
reason for his move if we cannot do that
if we cannot understand why all pawn and
play the move not okay now sometimes we
play not smart moves okay great
but let's say that you play the move
with a big threat this has to be
automatic so we have to protect these
squirrels what's the best way to protect
this squirrel
lucozade it's it's a decent way to to
defend but you can do that exactly this
in a much better way yes
so we will do exactly we will have our
look to f8 but we will also have our
King safe so this where is defended and
white most likely already moved a knight
will probably after they move h6 the
knight will move back because giving the
bishop and the night for the pawn and
the walk right why does the possibility
to capture black will capture white will
capture and that will capture white will
win the hook and the pawn and black will
win the night and their bishop right
it's tight you know it's about the same
but it's tiny bit more usually I will
say they in general two minor pieces in
this type of position are worth tiny bit
more than the rook probably six that
will give another I would say maybe six
and a half tiny bit more because how
they are working together so a logical
move will be to play in this position I
like to move this read the most on
Knight c3 let's go with Knight c3
Castle let's say now I place d3 and they
play these six let's go one you want a
pin it right that's a decent move let's
say this is the position that that we
have ah I'll just play one more move and
we will stop you this is one of the most
basic way to develop okay we are here
perfect
they this is one of the most basic
positions that you see in kids play yes
that's an excellent question
excellent question oh maybe maybe yeah
maybe you can help me yes why did I play
it to you you are officially my
assistant officially yes that's
excellent
all right yes I wanted to prevent a
black could have done the same but
basically it's just a simple there was
no necessity to play this move but it is
kind of healthy to have this move on the
board just to avoid this pain black by
the way could have done the same in
purpose I mixed it up a bit
yes safety square for the King right
that's perfect but that's yes that is a
tiny bit more advanced concept that I
didn't touch now but you're perfect
the King will have a evacuation square
you know in chess we call it some space
airlift you know it's a German word for
exactly the king at some point if the
king will be checked on the back rank
the king is able to move to h2 this is a
very and extremely healthy play by both
players you know if you have to compare
it everyone was eating the fruit and
vegetables for white and black and doing
everything according to normal play what
did they do you let's put it in C in
several stages first both players have
some points to fight for the center
right so both let's have some pawns
present in the center yes
you know it's a question that they just
answer I will answer it quickly just
specifically to what you said and look
if I play the smooth g3 you can come and
tell me correctly
look you have created some weaknesses
here G 2 is now weak and the bishop can
go to H 3 tiny bit weakening the King if
I play this specific move H 3 all the
squares around the King I'll covered the
pawn on f2 protecting g3 and e3 the pawn
on g2 protecting h3 and afteri they all
know will weaknesses that white is
created by playing this move we are not
saying that we will never ever ever move
upon around our King we will just do it
in a way that will be less weakening h3
doesn't really create any weakness but I
understand your question that's why I
touched it so we have this position and
I just want it
we have pawns in the center each player
developed is minor pieces so at a normal
opening stage one should have two or
three minor pieces developed quite
quickly
pawns minor pieces developed quite
quickly and castling so we will be safe
if you do that you will get in very very
few troubles in the opening just very
very simple we control some space we
have our pieces to help us control the
space and support the pawns
I will king in safe we are ready to
start the middle game now I have just
one comment / question we would usually
think about moving the knight earlier
than the bishops why is that
why would we first usually think about
moving our nights earlier than the
bishop
Oh any night I will say this first of
all something like you didn't you never
ever want to trade something in chess
have you ever had Never Say Never Never
Say Never right we can say that you for
example if you had say that usually or
many times it is preferable to keep the
pair of Bishops we will agree on that
okay but I think that is the first point
that you made I think you are correct
but you didn't you didn't explain it the
way that I want it I think that what you
want to say is right but I want to hear
someone else maybe
yes wife wife first denied and not the
bishop
IIIi would let me see if I can put it in
my words and if it will be matching
exactly what both of you wanted to say
let's look at this position the big
white bishop on c1 and black bishop on
CA are not developed they are not
developed now does it mean that they are
not part of the game they are not they
are not develop are they are they
controlling some squares they are
controlling a lot of squares because
that my assistants they said it when
when it was asked my assistant said I
was
he said because h3 preventing the visual
form coming to g4 right but this is
exactly the point look this bishop he
didn't move so you will say hey it's not
part of the game but bishops are very
long range pieces that's why it was said
before that in an endgame bishops are
extremely powerful right because the
position usually get open and the bishop
can control all the diagonals a pair of
bishops are incredibly strong